you're watching american history tv only
on c-span three
each week real america brings you
archival films that provide context for
today's public affairs issues
sponsored by the student nonviolent
coordinating committee also known as
snick will never turn back as a half
hour film that was used in their voter
registration campaign in the south shot
in rural mississippi the film includes
interviews with black farmers and
sharecroppers who describe violence and
intimidation they experienced when
attempting to register to vote julian
bond fannie lou hammer and snick leaders
also appear in the documentary
this picture is is essentially for
americans people who call themselves
americans it's about those in the south
today who are trying to make democracy
live
it begins with the painful and heartfelt
that we are not an island of perfection
but in fact
a
land of imperfection in an imperfect
world
negroes are trying to
register to vote and help to change the
situation that they're existing under
today help to bring about
democracy in our land today
[Music]
mississippi 1963
freed
for a moment
in this hillside home
they are secluded from the white
segregationists who carry guns and clubs
i miss i've been living in a mid county
52 or three years
i participated in everything
as they kind of saw fit for a citizen to
participate in
and also i read my family here in the
mid county
nine health children's
i only have two kids now going to
school
here in the county
i also was a
president of the naacp here in mid
county
and i would i do think that every
citizen
in the mid county should
to participate in an election
and i hope and trust
that i will have the privilege
to vote once or twice in my life
i'm mrs stanley hamer and i farmed on
the marlow plantation for 18 years
i had charge of keeping up with the time
and paying off and i went down the 31st
of august to try to register and after i
had gotten back home mr marlowe told me
that i would have to go down
and withdraw my registration or leave
because they wasn't ready for that in
mississippi and i said mr milo i'm
trying to register for myself so i had
to leave that same night after i had
gone down in august
and then i spent one night with mrs
tucker and after about two days in
september they shot in the house 15
times thinking that i was there
resistance to change in the south is
great
and behind the headlines
there's a story of intimidation that is
seldom
told
the police dogs the
police brutality
the
use of fire holes and and
other forms of intimidation to turn
negroes back it's what hits the
headlines daily but there's a story
that's yet to be told
[Music]
washing up the freedom
mrs mcgee tries to make a living on a
farm for herself and four teenage
children
they sent me to the hospital
they put my lane in the side bank
they got a thousand ninety five dollars
they ran into other land for 375 dollars
they put my children on welfare
when i came out of the hospital they had
taken my fence down and widen the road
down through my place they went around
got all of my creditors different people
that i owed to trust me
and they hadn't paid anybody
i got a lawyer to straighten my business
out
and he told me that he would
well he
didn't do anything about it he worried
me about selling some of the lane i told
him that i didn't want to sell the lane
that i wanted to punish so that i could
farm and make a living for my children
and so they just put pressure on me they
cut the wear off that check
to twenty dollars a month then they cut
it to seventeen dollars a month
they worried me so that i had a nervous
breakdown in sixty i had to go back to
the hospital
so when i came back
i came back home
i still tried to get a punish
he collected all the money read on the
place he didn't pay the federal lane
back the notes that i hold
they put pressure on me trying to get me
to sell the lane i refuse
so last year
i rented a portion of the lane for 200
cash he got that 200 he didn't give us
any of
i went down to illinois to reddish
and vote i got down and made my revival
back
my landlord said unto me if you don't go
down take your name off the registration
to move
i took his word and i moved
to drew mississippi
couldn't get too much pressure to be on
the landlord there
had been a move on to cleveland
mississippi
after arriving to cleveland mississippi
my wife
she had to go to the hospital down to
jackson
is there on the same generation
and i didn't know what step to take i'm
still working nine girls here
i'm working trying to take care of them
the best of my knowledge
this is mrs mildred evans she's 32 years
of age she's lived on mr w d fields
plantation for 11 years
she's above eight children
her children do not attend school
regularly because of food
clothing
and money last year mrs evans made 11
bales of cotton
at the end of the year she only received
123 dollars
i am 17 years old i pick 300 pounds of
academy a day
i am 9 years old i help my mother pick
out i pick a honda by day
i am 14 years old and i help my mother
see cat i ain't picked by 200 a day
this is mrs p williams the great
grandmother of the five children here
she receives a small social security
check each month and from this she must
help support the children that mothers
earn and take care of
the reason i do
because my mother worked her crop and i
had to help her and so i quit school
so that i could help her
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
and the two girls and our daughter were
sitting on the
chair and they were
the girl was badly shot up and they had
to be rushed to the hospital
and and they suffered very much
we went over to see them and they were
very much in pain they had to be rushed
to another hospital in jackson
and one had to go and this is the
results
after i had uh
registered
my name is child i was working in rural
mississippi on the night of the
shootings
1762. i went to the hospital to check on
the condition of the two girls who had
been shot and was arrested shortly after
my arrival there by the mayor of the
town of louisville i spent the night in
jail
talking to the mosquitoes
with no charges preferred against me
the night the shot was made in my house
it was no one that would mean my wife
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
of
[Music]
the next day when i reckless six months
last six month employment conversation
my name is eddie nunnery
lady of a mitch county and live in the
state of mississippi
i've gone
to try to radish at this
register office
and after going there several times
they failed me and told me i was
disqualified to register
and after going there
once
it was a gone fight
lots of people in amid county are fair
to go to liberty and register our vote
because they're afraid of being killed
lots of them are afraid to join the
naacp because they'll be afraid to lose
their job and have to go hungry
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
i'm willie peacock the field secretary
for the student nonviolent coordinating
committee at president i'm working in
greenwood mississippi
in lower florida county on voter
registration
our present activities are the
distribution of the food
which has been sent from the north
as an emergency relief
we feel that this this particular food
will will serve the needs of the needy
to the greatest advantage
i think that that
they are very appreciative of this
and i think that they have fear enough
concern about them
[Music]
all them silas they went to jail had no
money for to go their bail keep your
eyes on the prize
foreign
[Music]
i am william wesley i have gone down to
liberty mississippi
several times to try to register to vote
the second time i went down
the red stuff which was filling out the
form
of or gone far when the grandfather
i went out to see
what was happening my sons remain on in
filling out
when i come back we left my son when we
left our massan say uh
mr
white man coming across the hall and
told mr come
someone body got the hell shot out of
him and he said he sure did
and the last time we went out fill out
the farm we complete
our farms
they asked them how did we come out he
said we had to come back in several days
they'd go around the publication several
days was up we went back in he said we
had several more days and when several
more days was up we went back down see
how it would come out and he got his
chair and pulled it to the desk and we
all sit down he went over the
application just like some pace and some
didn't
and got to the
end of them
none of us didn't pass and so i asked
him what did i fail on my application or
my section or duty of a system and he
replied all of us
my name is maver lee weather i live in
liberty mississippi i was one of the
first ones to go to liberty to register
to vote
and wasn't anything said that day
because the office was very surprised
then later i carried some more people
and they did not finish because they
began to beat grit travis and they got
scared and ran out
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
[Music]
let your children go
[Music]
if
[Music]
and the young people there is hope
many of them have
dropped out of school for a year or more
to work as field secretaries for the
student nonviolent coordinating
committee
going into the rural areas of the south
to register people to teach the people
how to register and vote and to use the
franchises as an effective means of
change they exist on 10 and 15 dollars a
week living with the people working with
the people trying to build new horizons
for tomorrow
i as a young [ __ ] grow up mr says
feel that um
he is not wanted
because due to the fact
the white people of the south
they don't seem to understand the
younger generation of negroes
uh
we want to put up with the president of
our situation
it makes the internet grow
uh who is sensible
uh kind of angry when he hears uh
any uh
personal next negro
why do you want to do this do that why
you want to vote why you want to go to
uh the university of mississippi
well uh i think that the uh negro should
not be able to choose his own
institution as the
white uh youth when he finishes high
school
i think
that the negroes should be treated just
like the flight
i think when i would finish high school
that i would try to enter the college of
ole miss
as of james murder
my name is emma bell i'm from macomb
mississippi i'm 19 years of age i'm a
field secretary for the student
nonviolent club coordinating committee
i'm working for i'm working on voter
education programs in greenville
mississippi
i feel that the negroes in the south
especially the younger ones
would like to have the same
opportunities and privileges that any
other american citizen would have
and living within the system of
segregation they are aware that this
cannot ever exist
therefore they are willing to work and
fight much harder to do
to do away with segregation
uh the reason why i'm in the movement in
the south
is because i think that things have
gotten to the point where people have to
do things for themselves
they've got to stop depending on the the
federal government or the state
governments or even the local
governments to secure their rights for
them they've got to act to win the
rights that the constitution guarantees
and people must make up their minds that
if they want to be free and if they want
others to be free then they've got to do
something
something beyond just giving money or
just casting a vote
or just wishing others well but they've
got to
put their bodies in the movement as we
say they've got to get out on the front
lines and they've
got to do something for themselves and
for other people
my name is james jones i'm 20 years old
i was arrested and documented for
participating in the freedom ride i was
charged with bridget defeats incentive
practices and attention
while required being there two weeks
we heard the girls singing on the other
side
so we asked one of the trusted what was
wrong he told us that the guards are
taking the girls mattress so we decided
that we would protest that same night we
all started to sing it the shed came
down and put us in solitary solitary
about six feet wide
seven feet tall he put 27 of us in
solitary and that night one of the
fellows panicked another guy painted and
so we decided we would cool down
and
and asked the guard and asked the
sheriff to let us out so he let us out
and now that i'm out of boxington
attention i'm now working on voter
registration in sunflower county
parliament is located in sunflower
county
and i'm the seed of the sun
gonna stay right here and fight to feed
them until the spell is won
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't listen to mr charlie don't listen
to his life but color folks haven't got
a chance unless we organize
boys
[Music]
for the very basic right to vote in our
country there's seemingly an endless
chain of violence
you uh lived in mississippi
to register
the uh rare shot gave me some paper to
fill out i've done the very best i could
and i turned them in after i turned them
in i
left
and then as i was leaving a group of
white men was interfering with some of
my friends
and i got them in my truck and got in
the way as quick as i could
name is curtis dawson i was born
and raised in a mid-county
i was in liberty mississippi on the way
to the courthouse
but to reduce
the vote me and
knox
and
moses
we met three
white mens
and one of those men's jumped on moses
and began to beat him
herbert lee
was the father
of some nine children in the mid county
mississippi the county is 54 percent
negro
he tried very
hard to get his fellow citizens out to
register and vote
he was killed by a state representative
from mississippi a white state
representative after he himself had
tried to vote
these are pictures of his wife
and his nine children
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no
the director of the student nonviolent
coordinating committee's voter
registration project in mississippi
robert
moses young people working with the
student nonviolent coordinating
committee or snick as we call it
are characterized by restless energy
radical change in race relations in the
united states their world is upset
and they feel that if they are ever
going to get it straight
they must upset it more
my name is charles mclaren i work in
voter registration in sunflower county
on january 25th 1963
i went to the mayor's office in
indianola mississippi
my purpose the purpose was to see if
there were any laws on the book
that forbidden voter registration
activities in the city the mayor jumped
from his seat and
said you black son of a [ __ ] don't you
come in here arguing at me
i told him that we were there to do
voter registration
and that if there were any laws that
forbid it to let me know
and he said
he said no i turned and walked away
and he called me back
said
go out and teach everybody in the town
i don't care but if you go into any
churches
i will cut off the tax exemption
my name is jesse harry and i participate
in voter registration in the mississippi
delta it was during
1962 i was arrested in jackson for
contempt of court and fined one hall of
fine and 30 days in hinds county farm
the first time i was beaten was in hinds
county on the elevator when office asked
me my name and where i was from and i
told him i'm from jackson and so he beat
me and hit me side to head in the back
and thing the second time i was beating
on the hinds county farm
because he asked me where i was out from
also and i told him jackson and he said
are you one of those freedom riders and
i told him i didn't know what it was so
he beat me and the third time i was
beaten was on the counter phone because
i refused to move a 200 pound loss
and the fourth time i was beating
because
my name is hollis watkins i participated
in a demonstration in macomb mississippi
and was arrested for breach of peace
along with 115 other students
while a mob waited on the outside after
being questioned i was carried into a
room where a police officer came in and
got a rope and said okay [ __ ] get up
from here and let's go we're going to
have a hanging here tonight and you're
going to be first i looked at the
officer as he looked at me and then he
walked out
i am samuel black
field secretary for the student
nonviolent coordinating committee
i've been working in greenwood
mississippi in florida county
my purpose of being in greenwood is to
teach the negroes their duties and
obligations responsibilities for
citizenship on the constitutional form
of government
by doing this i teach how important
validity is and voter registration
when my first trip to the courthouse i
carried eight people up to register i
was met by the sheriff
he asked me where was i from
i told him i was a native mississippian
he said yes yes yes i know that but
where are you from i told him i was a
native mississippian around him here
someplace he said well what count i said
well brown here's some of these kind of
well
he got angry
he spit it in my face
he walked away
he turned around and came back
he put his finger in my face he said
look
he said
i know every [ __ ] is mammy around here
i actually didn't know any color people
he looked at me
and he
walked away again and he came back
he said look
so i don't want to see you right in here
no no more in this county
say i want you to leave town pack your
bag and leave town right now get out of
town don't let me catch you around here
no more
so i wasn't
frightened i looked at him i told him my
sheriff
if you don't want to see me around here
in town in the morning the best thing
for you to do
is pack your bags and leave
cause i'll be here
i knew that i wasn't leaving
today in 1963
the fight to enjoy the rights of
first-class citizenship is still being
waged in this country
the needs of the people on the front
line are great you need typewriters
papers
money for food and anything
that you can
find that is useful you can find
anything that is useful it can be sent
to the student nonviolent coordinating
committee
six raymond street
atlanta georgia
help us who have fought for so many
years
to make the world
safe for democracy
and our fight now to make democracy safe
for the world
[Music]
then
[Music]
you can watch archival films on public
affairs in their entirety on our weekly
series real america
saturday at 10 pm and sunday at 4 pm
eastern here on american history tv
it seemed to be happening just about
every week that somebody either a famous
person